voilà c'est ensuite d'or ces lutteurs et
on commence avec les plus gros clash
politique n'avait qu'une année
présidentielle électorat double double
élection où les anciennes évidemment et
forcément quand les politiques se
rencontrent sur un plateau c'est
rarement pour se dire des mots darty on
vous a fait une pluie de sélection voici
les nommés
dans la catégorie award du meilleur
clash politique les nommer son ami place
rigaud et alexis corbière dans les
embrouilles de cour de récré à continuer
vos nerfs
sont enseignées en 2022 c'est fini pour
vous lécher des
[Applaudissements]
mourides jean luc mélenchon qui ne se
sont jamais entendus mais vous en avez
d'autres monsieur de la palice
je suis sourde de paix et de naissance
les quelque chose contre les handicapés
j'ai remarqué
daniel cohn-bendit pour son calme
légendaire face à luc ferry
et rachida dati pour ses punchlines
sortie d'un autre monde face à
clémentine autain vous n'avez pas le
monopole de quoi que ce soit et on voit
comment vous avez fracturé les
territoires vous êtes responsable d'une
grande partie de ses parts ainsi va la
france faut vous l'entendiez
[Musique]
keystone dès 6 heures
mais là les meilleurs punchline
généralement à moi j'aime bien mélenchon
et zemmour mélenchon zemmour fait
référence à sa surdité d'une oreille
quand même très gênant que l'on regarde
les handicapés aux événements mais là on
va se regarder zemmour et mélenchon dans
la longueur parce que c'est quand même
un grand moment tu as été inversé leur
encore en plus de 222 millions deux cent
huit mois
valentin que j'en passe
quand on aime travailler on a le droit
de s'arrêter
vous en avez d'autres routes arelys
leur voilà tout est dit j'ai dit est ce
que vous en avez ça re soir vous en avez
d'autres monsieur de la palice
je suis sourde le pee wee de naissance
les quelque chose contre les handicapés
j'ai remarqué
[Applaudissements]
la mpoc et vous sa colère quant à vous
est grossier vulgaire parce que vous
n'en vous détestez tout le monde va
voyons seulement un vrai handicap
famille qu'on doit regrouper oui c'est
ça alors vous gardez vos remarques vous
devriez réfléchir la chose que vous avez
sous les cheveux qui vous reste ça
s'appelle un cerveau ça fait
c'est vrai que la gaffe lagaf est énorme
dollar et vous voulez qu'on voit pas ce
que c'est quand même un bon moment vous
convoi luc ferry
c'est incroyable il y a dans la société
française et il y a dans les
institutions françaises du racisme de
l'antisémitisme
dans les institutions françaises il lit
et qu'elle en dit moins lesquelles par
exemple il y a dans la police brassant
il y avait là des gens racistes ya pas
dans la police du racing ben oui c'est
ce que je veux dire allez on vous laisse
assez content mais cette non non il est
soit finir monde mais aujourd'hui
n'importe quoi mais des conneries
la tienne pas crétin non mais qu'est ce
que dit que des mensonges en ce moment
dans la vie
je les connais très bien ils s'entendent
très bien et en fait c'est un rendez
vous qui a lieu tous les dimanches soir
sur lci et il se rentrent dedans assez
régulièrement c'est la voie appelée que
comme le dit qu'il est coutumier du fait
il s'emporte très vite vous rappeler de
son face à face avec collard ans et 2019
pas mal observé
le représentant de la république en main
mais les prenez là
vous exprimer ce qu'ils voient la
présence qui compte c'est ce qu'on
trouve à bord alors
allez je suis dehors des messieurs voilà
messieurs vont l'utiliser au moins on
arrivait à gagner
les faux culs de la politique ceux qui
ont dit
chocolat
monsieur collard
me collard monsieur godard monsieur
collard
[Applaudissements]
les politiques et souvent pour avoir
c'est pas mal d'immersion avec eux ils
sont hyper copains en dehors des
émissions et j'avais posé la question
justement eric zemmour je l'avais dit si
je vous met dans une maison tous
ensemble avec qui vous aimeriez le plus
et avec qui vous cachez riez plus il
m'avait répondu mélenchon il m'a dit
parce qu'on a plein d'idées en commun
etc etc il adorait produits locaux main
mais il avait choisi en tout cas les
opposés s'attirent oui c'est ça alors on
va remettre ses limites doha à rachida
merci à les regarder
non mais je vous ai pas demandé de
décoder mes propos là je lui pose la
glisse est pas une traduction je peux
lui dire dire l ordre et la fois écouter
madame boutin non mais ça va j'ai besoin
de vous j'ai besoin personne ne vous
n'avez pas le monopole de quoi que ce
soit et on voit comment vous avez
fracturé les territoires dont vous êtes
responsable d'une grande partie de ses
parents s'ils veulent en france pour
vous l'entendiez ça j'ai vraiment un
sentiment de muppet show l'envoyer à
manon de limoges
respecter s'il vous plaît il à ces
bombes et rachida gilbert sit in et vous
ferez mieux de baisser d'un ton parce
qu'on verra au deuxième tour
allez on a ses hauts ses beats d'or des
plus gros clash en divertissement et
beaucoup en tenir à l'été magali faut
pas se mentir les nominés
dans la catégorie award du meilleur
clash à la télé les mémés son oie et les
jumelles il meurt qui ont un peu trop
pris me l'ont handicapé 14 mentions
d'aidé
j'ai pas dit non tout soit prêt à 9 à 10
mois qu'il
touche pas mais affaire sur la vie de ma
mère tout ça mais à faire sur la tête de
ma mère je vais prendre tout tabac ni
tromperie
ni niccolò dans le partage compliqué des
tâches ménagères c'est juste un film et
chante donc j'aimerais cdh
tous les faire tu vas devenir et je sais
pas et singapour kg compte elle ne passe
décidément alors est-ce que tu m'entends
et si tu m'as tort que tu me dis pas
d'attaqué comme chef d'état
[Musique]
l'art est d'accord non c'est pas gagné
ils n'ont pas compris le maniement du
tokyo après ça marche pas du tout eu ces
huit d'or dans la catégorie gros clash
sûreté pmp alors là comme on dit qu'on
ne sait que choisir s'est d'abord les
nuits des 100 g
pour la catégorie award du meilleur
clash dans des pmp les nommés sont pida
turner et laurent fontaine dans la
réconciliation ou pas
[Applaudissements]
fabarez bernès dans la guerre des gilles
[Musique]
quénéhervé vas tu t'énerves et fois
tapas but est taillée dans un casse-cou
de bal musette
fabrice di vizio face à matthieu
delormeau dans son 257e départ plateau
si
ces bons fous ici bordeaux non mais
c'est
benjamin castaldi à la rescousse de son
fils vous allez arrêter de poids de
penser canaux sociaux c'est un déversoir
à merde et qu'on peut tout dire et tout
faire si je voulais avoir la loi
monsieur mcphee jouer l'armée serbe je
suis pas de mon fils et je
sais ce qui m'attend au kenya c'est quoi
la liane
[Musique]
alors je n'ai pas porté plainte pour des
questions de budget
[Rires]
puisque je vous tiens à mes gars je vous
avais vus sur les réseaux vous avez
lancé une pétition que je trouve
extrêmement louable pagne extrêmement
noble puisque magali berda milite pour
que on lève l'anonymat sur les réseaux
alors qu'on m'explique alors assez
brièvement ce que votre vidéo elle fait
cinquante minutes mais on l'élève d'une
certaine façon voilà en fait c'est à
dire que moi ce que je voudrais c'est
que les réseaux sociaux pour ouvrir des
comptes oblige d'avoir enfin obliger
gens de leur donner leur carte
d'identité tout simplement comme ça il
est gay on peut avoir un pseudo parce
qu'on n'a pas envie forcément dire son
nom etc je peux comprendre mais au moins
si un souci pour du harcèlement et bien
la police peut avoir accès à la carte
identité qui a ouvert le compte ça
limite aussi qu'une personne ouvre un
compte et 50 15 comptes et harcèlent
quinquin en meute et parce que c'est
très grave et aussi sa protégera les
enfants parce que en dessous d'un
certain âge on n'a pas être sur les
réseaux sociaux il ya des règles et du
coup ils pourront s'assurer de l'âge de
la personne qui veut qu'on donc ça
pourra régler plein de problèmes en une
seule chose juste demander la carte
d'identité à l'ouverture du compte alors
comment être qu'on peut signer
[Applaudissements]
les opinions 1 point comme et on a déjà
en trois jours je crois plus de 20000 à
25000 signature donc c'est quand même au
bowling au bout de combien on a une
chance d'aller à l'assemblée et puis je
crois que c'est sans mines non ça c'est
par ici on va y arriver à tout faire
pour que vous puissiez avoir autant de
boussens mille signatures on va quand
même de leur boîte division parce que
division nous a quand même offert un
festival toute l'année et c'est vrai que
quand division et sur le plateau s'est
jamais sera on va pas se mentir on a
toujours envie de bad lui hurler dessus
en pétain et voilà
généralement ces mesures entre le pass
vaccinale le confinement le couvre-feu
tout c'est l'ensemble finalement des
choses qui a abandonné contribué un
sentiment de mal être de la population
qu'il ne faut pas négliger ce hameau
avec la prise de risque
concernant des
vaccins
pour leurs enfants étudiants volumen son
père perturbant
amertume qui sous
la houlette de tous les québécois se bat
pas respecté les galaxies suicide comme
ça et et les pays qui ont
suffi à les toits c'est bon
vous avez une et de souligner que cette
directeur dans lequel on ne sait pas
pourquoi il est là mais
moi senti sourire au coin où il est
content et soulagé l'aïe a dit monique
des bulles moi je pense qu'on va
remettre le cmaj et ouest
[Applaudissements]